hi i'm trevor hasting and i'm rob
tiptoroni
hi
and then you say welcome to the course
on cisco hi i'm trevor hastie and i'm
rob
hi i'm trevor no i'm rob tipsarani and
i'm trevor hastie
and welcome to our course on statistical
learning this is the first online course
we've ever ever given i'm really excited
to tell you about it and a little
nervous as you can hear
so uh by way of background what is
statistical learning
um trev and i are both statisticians we
were actually graduate students here at
stanford in the 80s we've known each
other for about 30 years oh my goodness
and uh back then uh well we did applied
statistics like a lot of statisticians
did statistics been around since about
1900 or before
but in the 1980s people in computer
science developed a field of machine
learning
especially neural networks became a very
hot topic i was at university of toronto
and trevor was at bell labs
and one of the first neural networks was
developed at bell labs to solve the the
zip code recognition problem which we'll
show you a little bit about in in in a
few slides so around that time uh trevor
and i and then some colleagues jerry
friedman uh brad ephron
brian leo bryman and you actually you'll
hear from jerry and brad both in in this
course we have some interviews with them
about that time we started to work on
the area of machine learning and sort of
developed our own view of it which was
now called cisco learning so we're one
of the along with colleagues here at
stanford and other places we developed
this field of statistical learning
so in this course we'll talk to you
about some of the developments in this
area and give lots of examples so let's
start with our first example
which is
a computer program playing jeopardy
called watson that ibm built
and it it beat uh
the players in in a three-game match and
the the the people at ibm who developed
the system said it was really a triumph
of machine learning there were a lot of
very smart technology both hardware but
also the software and the algorithms
were based on machine learning so this
was a
a watershed moment i think for the area
of artificial intelligence and machine
learning
google is is a big user of data and a
big analyzer of data and
here's a quote that came in the new york
times in 2009 from hal varian as the
chief economist at google you can see
the quote there keep saying that the
sexy job in the next 10 years will be
statisticians and indeed there's a
picture of carrie grimes who was a
graduate from stamford statistics she
was one of the first statisticians hired
at google now google has many
statisticians
our next example this is a picture of
nate silver on the right and nate has a
masters in economics but he calls
himself a statistician
and he writes at least he did write a
blog called 538 for the new york times
and in that blog along uh he he
predicted the outcome of the 2012
presidential and senate elections uh
very very well matter of fact he got all
this the the the the senate races right
and the uh the presidential election he
he predicted very very accurately using
statistics using carefully uh carefully
sampled data from various places some
careful analysis he did an extremely
accurate job of predicting the election
when a lot of places where a lot of news
outlets weren't sure who's going to win
pretty nerdy looking guy isn't he rob
yes but he's very famous and uh he's
like a rock star these days yes we joke
about when you're a statistician when
you go to a party and tell someone says
well you know what do you do you say i'm
a statistician they run for the door
right but nowadays we can say well we do
machine learning and uh well they still
run for the door but it take a little
longer to get there
in fact we now call ourselves data
scientist it's a trendier word
so we're going to run through a number
of statistical learning problems um you
can see it there's a bunch of examples
on this page and we'll go through them
one by one just to give you a flavor of
what's what sorts of problems we're
going to
be thinking about
so the first the first data set we're
going to look at is on prostate cancer
this is a relatively small data set 97
men
sampled from 97 men with prostate cancer
actually by stanford
physician dr stamey in the late 80s
and
what we have is the psa measurement for
each subject along with a number of
clinical and blood measurements from the
patients some measurements on the cancer
itself
and and some measurements from from the
blood
um the measurements to do with cancer
size and the
the the severity of the cancer
and this is a scatter plot matrix which
which actually showed that shows the
data
and you see on the diagonal is the name
of each of the variables and each little
plot is a pair of variables so you get
in one picture if you've got a
relatively small number of variables you
can see all the data at once in in a
picture like this and you can see
the nature of the data what variables
are correlated and so on and so this is
a good way of of of getting a view of
your data
and
in this particular case the the
the
the goal was to try and predict the psa
from from the other measurement so it's
along the top and you can see there's
some correlations between these
measurements
here's actually another view of these
data
which
looks rather similar except in in the
one instance over here which is this is
the log weight these variables on the
log scale
and this is log weight
and you notice there's a point over here
it looks like somewhat of an outlier
well it turns out on the log scale it
looks a bit like an outlier but when you
when you look on the normal scale it's
enormous
and basically that was a typo and that
would say if that was a real measurement
it would say that a patient
this particular patient would have a um
a 449 gram prostate
well we got an uh message from a retired
urologist dr steven link who pointed
this out to us and and so um we
corrected an earlier published version
of this of the scatter plot which is a
good thing to remember the first thing
to do when you get a set of data for
analysis is not to run it through a
fancy algorithm make some graphs some
plots look at the data i think the old
days before computers people did that
much more because it was it was easy i
mean you do it by hand and the analysis
took many many hours so people would
look first the data much more and we
needed to keep remember that that even
with big data you should look at it
first before you you jump in with an
analysis
so the next example is um phonemes
for two vowel sounds
and this is looking at this graph has
the a log periodograms of
uh for two different phonemes the power
at different frequencies for two
different phonemes uh a a
a and a o how do you pronounce those
trevor a is odd and ao is ought
as you can tell trevor talks funny but
hopefully during the course you'll be
able to
say no
odd and hot
okay okay so
you see the the log periodograms at
various frequencies of of um these two
vowel sounds are spoken by different
people the orange and the green
and the goal here was to try to classify
the
two vowel sounds based on the power at
different frequencies
so on the bottom
we see a logic model has been fit to the
the data
looking at trying to classify the two
classes from each other based on the the
power of different frequencies the
loaded models from logistic regression
which is used to to classify into one of
the two vowel sounds based on the
log periodogram and we'll cover it in
detail in the course and the the
coefficients the estimated coefficients
from the logistic model are in the gray
uh
profiles here in the bottom plot and you
can see
they're very non-smooth
it you'd be hard-pressed to tell where
the important frequencies were
but when you apply a kind of smoothing
which we'll also discuss in the course
which will use the fact that the nearby
frequency should be similar
right which the the uh the gray did not
exploit we get the red curve and the red
curve shows you pretty clearly that the
important frequencies
looks like um the one vowel sounds got
more power around 25
and the other vowel sound has more power
around just before 50.
predict whether someone will have a
heart attack on the basis of demographic
diet and clinical measurements
so these are some data on
on
actually men from south africa the red
ones are those that had heart disease
and the blue points are those that
didn't it's a case control sample so all
the heart attack cases were taken as
cases and a sample of the controls were
made and the idea was to understand the
risk factors
in in heart disease now when you have a
binary response like this you can color
the scatter plot matrix so you can see
the points which is rather handy
and these these data come from a region
of south africa where the heart the risk
of heart disease is very high it's over
over five percent for this age group the
people the the
especially men around they eat lots of
these were men
they eat lots of meat they have meat for
all three meals
and in fact
meat so prevalent
chickens regarded as a vegetable
pork chicken rob loves it
i used to love that job okay so again
you can see there's correlations in
these data
and
and the goal here is to is to filter for
the model that jointly involves all
these different risk factors in in
coming up with a risk model for for
heart disease which in this case is not
is is
as i said colored in red
our next example is email spam detection
now as
everyone uses email and spam is
definitely a problem
and so
spam filter is a very important
application of cisco and machine
learning the data in this on this table
actually
um i think it's from the maybe the late
90s
is that right before yeah late 90s
exactly it's from hewlett-packard so
this is a person named george who worked
at hewlett-packard so this was early in
the days of email where
as well spam was also not very
sophisticated so what we have here is
data from over 4 000 emails sent to an
individual named george at hp labs
each one's been hand labeled as either
being spam or good email and the goal
here is to try to predict actually they
call good email ham these days right
okay
so
the goal was to classify
spam from ham based on the frequencies
of words in the in the email
so here we just have a summary table of
some of the more important features
so
it's based on um
words and characters in the email so for
example this is saying that if this
email had george in it it was more
likely to be good email than spam
back then if someone you know if you saw
your name's george and you saw george in
your email it was more likely to be good
email nowadays of course spam is much
more um sophisticated they know your
name they know a lot about your life and
um the fact that your name's it actually
it made me a smaller chance it's
actually good email but back then this
the spam
spammers were much less sophisticated so
for example if your name was in it your
smart chance to be high email what's
with that remove word rob uh remove okay
so i guess it probably says something
like don't remove is that right
i think it says
if you want to be removed from this list
click i see that's usually a spam right
so
the goal was that
and we'll talk about this example in
detail to use the the the 57 features
and here's these are seven of those
features as a classifier together to try
to predict whether an email is spam or
ham
identify the numbers in a handwritten
zip code this is what we were alluding
to earlier here's some handwritten
digits taken from envelopes
and
the goal is to
based on an image of any of these digits
to to say what the digit is is to to
classify into the 10 digit classes
well to humans this looks like a pretty
easy task
um you know we're pretty good at pattern
recognition turns out it's a notoriously
difficult task for for computers are
getting better and better all the time
so this this was one of the first
learning tasks that was used
to
develop neural networks neural networks
were first brought to bear on this
problem
and
you know we thought we thought this
should be an easy uh problem to crack
turns out it's really difficult
actually i remember the first time
trevor that we worked on a machine
learning problem is this problem and you
were working at bell labs i visited bell
labs and you just gotten this data and
you said these people in artificial
intelligence are working on this and
that we thought oh let's try some
statistical methods and we tried uh
discriminant analysis right that's right
we got an error rate of about eight and
a half percent and the best error rate
in about 20 minutes right and the best
error rate anyone else had was about
four or five percent at that point we
thought oh this is going to be easy
we're already at eight percent in 10 or
15 minutes
six months later they just want to say
we're maybe at the same place so we
realized actually you know as often as
the case
you can get some of the signal pretty
quickly but getting down to a very good
error rate uh in this case trying to
trying to classify some of the harder to
classify
things like maybe this four
or actually most things are pretty easy
but if you if you look at the database
some of them are very hard so hard that
the human eye can't really tell what
they are or it has difficulty and those
are the ones that the machine learning
algorithms have are
really challenged by anyway it's a
lovely problem and it's fascinated
machine learners and statisticians for a
long time
so the next example comes from from
medicine classifying a tissue sample
into into one of several cancer classes
based on the gene expression profile so
trevor and i both work in the medical
school part-time here at stanford and a
lot of what we do and others do is to
try to use machine learning cisco
learning big data analysis to
learn about
data in cancer and other diseases so
this is an example of that this is data
in breast cancer
it's called gene expression data so this
has been collected from gene chips and
what we see here on the left is a matrix
of data
each row is a gene and there's about 8
000 genes here i think
and each column is a patient and this is
called a heat map
so what this heat map is representing is
low and high gene expression for a given
patient for a given gene so green being
low and red meaning high and gene
expression means the gene is working so
if a gene is expressing it's working
hard in the cell if it's not expressing
it's it's quiet it's silent
and the the goal was to try to figure
out which genes we'll try to figure out
the pattern of gene expression these are
patients these are women with with
breast cancer trying to figure out the
common patterns of gene expression for
for women with breast cancer and seeing
why their subcategories of breast cancer
showing different gene expression so we
see here is a heat map of the full data
88 women in the columns and about again
about 8 000 genes in the rows
and
hierarchical clustering which we'll
discuss in the last part of this course
has been applied to the columns and you
see the clustering tree at the top here
which has been expanded
for your view at the top
and hierarchical clustering has been
used to divide these women into roughly
one two three four five six subgroups
based on the gene expression they're
very effective
especially with these colors you can
just see these clusters standing out
yeah hierarchical clustering and heat
maps actually been a very important
contribution for genomics which is this
is an example of simply because they
enable you to see and organize the full
set of data on just in a single picture
and the bottom right here is some more
we've drilled down to look more at the
the gene expression like for example
this subgroup here these red patients
seem to be high largely in these genes
and maybe in these genes
so we'll talk about this example in
detail later on the course
establish the relationship between
celery and demographic variables in the
populations in population survey data so
here's some survey data
um
we see income
from the central and atlantic region of
the usa in in 2009 and you see what you
might expect to see as a function of age
income
initially goes up then levels off and
then finally goes down as
as people get older
incomes gradually increase with year as
the cost of living increases
and incomes change with with education
level that's the right hand plot those
are box plots
and
so here we see the the three in three of
the variables that affect income and
again the goal is we use regression
models to try and understand the roles
of these variables together and see if
there's you know if there's interactions
and so on
and our last example is um
landsat images of of land use
uh area in australia so this is a rural
area of australia those are harsh colors
rob did you did you choose those colors
uh you probably did every year the uh
color this is color developed taste
when did that happen
i didn't see the
news memo okay so
here are
uh these are from landsat images so
let's start here in the in this panel so
this is again a rural area of australia
where the
land use has been labeled i think
actually by
my graduate students or or
researchers into one of one two three
four five six
they don't have to pay their the the
graduate students as much there
as we do so they've been labeled uh and
these colors are indicating the
different labels these are the true
labels and the goal is to try to predict
these two labels from
the
spectral bands at four frequencies taken
from a satellite image and so here's the
here's the power at the different
frequencies
uh in four spectral bands
so we have features which are now
they're pretty complicated because we
have features
spatial features four layers of them and
we're going to try to use those
combination of features to predict the
the land use that we see here
and pixel by pixel pixel pixel although
we might want to use the fact that
nearby pixels are more likely to be the
same land use than ones that are far
away
and we'll talk about classifiers i think
the one we use here is actually nearest
neighbors a very simple classifier and
that produces the prediction in the
bottom right and you can see it's quite
good it's not perfect there's a few
mistakes it makes
but it's for the most part quite
accurate
okay so that's that's the end of the
series of examples in the next session
we'll just tell you some notation and
how we set up problems for supervised
learning
which we'll use for the rest of the
course